Hi, I'm Michelle Klein, member of
the GSB Alumni Association Board, and
I'm pleased to welcome
you to this production
[MUSIC]
>> Yeah,
change the organization change the world
[MUSIC]
>> If not you then who?
If not, you then who?
You are sitting here,
on the precipice of leaving the GSB
with the whole world in front of you,
and you can do anything.
And yet some of you are not
sure what your next step is.
Some of you are not sure if
your job is the perfect fit and
some are wondering,
what were these two years about?
Am I any less confused
than when I started?
The point of today,
is to let you know that you are absolutely
prepared for this next step.
That you all have superpowers,
you all unique and talented and
you inspire me every single day.
So, we're going to talk
about my life lessons and
I'm going to wrap it around story
you know I love storytelling.
So let's get started,
something you won't believe coz here I am,
kind of pushy New Yorker telling you
all these things you should be doing.
But I was the shyest kid,
I hid behind my mom.
And it would take a lot for me to speak
up in class or put myself out there.
I grew up with a twin brother, Adam.
Yeah, we were dressed that way.
I have I grew up with
an older sister Jane.
A lot of my students know that she sends
me beautiful clothes are called Jamie
downs and I'm she protected me as well.
But around age nine, my personality
started to come, and I got a little sassy.
I even made some questionable fashion
choices, see elite I know you're very good
with fashion I don't know what you'd
think of my tartan cape here, but
it definitely made me stand out.
But through the years,
I came out of my shell,
I have these life experiences and
these jobs and I got my toolkit.
And what I've learned is that everything
you experience is something you can
leverage.
Even if it's a skill that's dormant and
you haven't used it in a few years,
you can unearth it and
bring it out at the right moments.
So here I am now in
front of all of you and
I'm going to share some of my beliefs and
my principles.
And these are my principles to live.
I'm going to read it because
I can't memorize them, but
I'm going to go over today
about leading with love.
When sad or
disappointed helps someone else.
Compassion over aggression.
Figure out how to connect to others.
Showing faith in others
leads to their success.
Let people know who you
are by telling your stories.
Listen when people tell you who you are.
Be accountable own your words and actions.
It's not what happens, it's how you deal
with it all my reputation management
people know that I believe in that.
And then of course, create your own
narrative I must say that 100 times.
And then finally which I teach
an executive presence, opt in and
then figure it out, but
don't hold yourself back out of fear.
So here I actually Emily covered this also
I don't really have to say anything but
I've been here nine years.
And I co created a course reputation
management with JD schrom.
That was my gateway class into here
to my drug addiction to the GSB.
And then I created Project You and
strategic pivoting and the two electives.
So today hopefully you will learn from my
past and hopefully it can help the future.
My first lesson is disappointment
can lead to something even better.
When I was at Camp summer camp,
New York City kids got sent away for
two months to summer camp, because their
parents needed to get them out of the way.
And I was auditioning for Godspell.
I think I was about nine years old and
the summer before I had been Wendy and
Peter Pan and I killed it.
So I'm like I'm a shoo in for God's spell.
And not only did I not get a roll,
but I didn't even get in the chorus.
So I go back to my cabin and
sit on my bed and
I'm like feeling so sorry for
myself and feeling misunderstood.
And my counselor comes over and
like Allison,
the youngest girls in bunk
two are putting on a play.
Why don't you go help them?
So it's like okay, so
I went down to bunk to and for
the next two weeks I was the director and
the costumer and the person who
practiced with them and the producer and
these kids put on a wonderful play.
Through that for some reason I got girl
of the week, and then eventually I got
colorwork captain and I had a reputation
as being a leader at my summer camp.
If I had gotten to Godspell,
yeah, I might have been good.
But none of that would have happened and
the lesson wouldn't have been learned for
me.
I really believe this, that when you
have difficult people in your life,
it's a challenge but
it's how you handle it.
My mom taught me, that first of
all you should lead with love.
But she also told me that when someone
is upset with you or angry or bullying,
it's because they're coming
from a place of hurt.
Hurt people, hurt people.
She's like try to think maybe
they're going through a rough time.
Maybe something's happening in
their home life, show compassion.
So I'm sure many of you have been in a
situation where fire meets fire someone's
>> When people are coming at you,
they want that interaction,
they want to engage you in
a way that can provoke them so
they can let out all that anger and
frustration.
But I really believe that if you meet fire
with a warm blanket and compassion and
empathy, well,
then you'll there'll be a greater
understanding in you can get things done.
When you meet someone who's angry with
compassion so you seem really upset,
can I help in any way or something's
going on what's going on with you.
You'll see all of a sudden the whole
body language just goes down and
like this is so frustrating.
And then you're like, how can I help and
all of a sudden, there's humanity.
Now, I wish so this is the takeaway,
you can only control your actions.
How many times you've said only they had
said this or they should have done this.
And I always say, yeah,
they should have but they didn't.
So how does that affect you?
How do you want to show up?
What's the leader that you want to be?
How would you handle the situation?
All you can do is show up,
the way you want to show up and
role model it and not let someone
else's bad behavior affect you.
Now, it'd be lovely if I took
my own advice but I didn't and
I had to learn the hard way.
When I was at the home shopping network,
which was run by Barry Diller and
Diane Von Furstenberg.
I came over from Good Morning America and
my job was to control the home department,
all the products,
that had to do with garden and kitchen.
And that's a whole another story coz
I don't cook and I don't garden but
I really am,
>> [LAUGH]
>> As Bert Alper says
don't let the truth get in
the way of a good story.
So, anyway I went over there to produce
and they matched you up with a producing
partner, and
they matched me up with this woman Emmy.
Emmy had her own reputation.
She was known as difficult and
sarcastic and kind of a malcontent.
So when she first met me,
she goes Allison, she goes, I'm so
glad I'm partnered with you.
I hear you're really friendly,
everybody loves you.
I hate people, so
you're going to be my buffer.
And I'm thinking, wet flag,
I'm in so much trouble.
But you know what, I'm like,
I'm going to make this work.
Maybe we can balance each other out.
So after two weeks our talent quit.
And they said, Alison,
you go on air, you sell products.
And I was like, okay, [LAUGH].
And so Amy felt betrayed and
abandoned by me.
And she was so angry at me.
And she would try to,
not even pass aggressively,
she just tried to undermine me.
She turned our whole team against me,
and she made comments about me.
You're all too young to know
the movie All About Eve.
But it's about a woman who'll do
anything to get into the movies.
So she would call me Eve.
Anyway, I asked her if I could go to
my husband's law school graduation.
She says, no, you can't go.
We need you.
And she said, you're so lucky.
I'm so understanding always.
And then I did the wrong thing.
I escalated.
And I said, no,
you have been a total bitch.
God.
>> [LAUGH]
>> First, and
only time I've used profanity.
And, boy.
It just, after that, she would talk in
my ear during live shows, it got so
much worse.
And all I realized is that moment
of satisfaction when I got to say
what I really felt.
It wasn't worth it.
I should have been strategic.
I should have figured out how to
get what I want, and I didn't.
And so that momentary feeling
of saying those bad words and
what you feel, it doesn't pay off.
I lost all control and
it really blew up in my face.
So my lesson for
that is take control and power, and
only I can take care of
how I react to things.
So you're not a pushover,
though, if you do this.
You're still a leader because
you're going to show empathy.
You're going to rely on
facts to make your argument.
You're going to come up with solutions.
You're going to set boundaries, hopefully.
And I don't know if anyone
recognizes this gentleman,
probably Mary Spicer does
because we're colleagues.
This was Joel Siegel from
Good Morning America.
He was a correspondent for movies.
And when I was an intern at GMA, he used
to take me to free screenings because I
was such an eager intern, and I loved him.
When I started working right out
of college, for some reason,
he likes to haze the new people.
And he came and he yelled at me in front
of a whole bunch of people and I was so
humiliated, but I was also really
hurt because I really admired him.
But I didn't say anything.
But the next day we were at the mailboxes,
because in those days,
that's how we communicate
[LAUGH] through mailboxes.
And he comes up, he's like, hey, Alison.
And I'm like, hi, Joel.
I said, Joel, I am so
upset with how you talk to me yesterday.
First of all, it was very unprofessional.
And second of all, it wasn't warranted.
And I really like you, and I admire you,
and I love working with you.
But I can't talk to you right now
because of what you did to me yesterday.
You could have blown him over.
I was 21 [LAUGH] but I had boundaries.
And I knew if I didn't set a precedent,
right, he might do it again.
And he said, Allison, I'm so sorry.
He talked like that, Allison.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And he's like, I'm so sorry.
And you know what, he never did it again,
and we were very close.
What I'm trying to say is that the
exception is if abuse is consistent, and
then you have to report it.
But otherwise,
you can tell anybody anything as long
as you say it in a nice way,
as long as you say it in a calm way.
So my next tip is connect
to others on a human level.
When I was at Penn, my first year I took
psychology, it was between psychology and
TV by the way, just so you know.
And there was this study
called the bystander effect.
I'm sure you've heard of it.
It's where the people, if it's a group of
people and someone's screaming for help,
and no one does anything.
There was a very big case called the Kitty
Genovese Case where a woman was stabbed in
a courtyard and screamed and
no one came out to help her.
But what the study said is,
if you can single one person out and
connect to them as a human being, it's
much more likely that they will help you.
So don't scream like fire on a train,
like go up to someone and say,
I need your help.
So I remember this and
I had an experience.
I was in London my junior year,
I was studying abroad.
And because I was a city girl,
I love taking the tube.
I thought it was much better
than the New York City subway.
And I was coming back from the library and
it was 11:30 at night.
And I got out on the platform and
it didn't occur to me how late it was.
And it was deserted.
And I get out, and
a group of young men who are obviously
drunk came out of a carriage a few down.
And they see me and they start
screaming at me and heckling me.
Hey, Miss America.
And my heart stopped.
I'm like, my god,
I'm going to be in a bad situation.
Why didn't I anticipate this?
And I remembered this, and
I started walking towards them.
And I said, hey,
how'd you know I was American?
Was it my down jacket and
sneakers that gave it away?
And then I went right up to the guy
who was obviously the leader.
And I said, hey, can you do me a favor?
I need someone to walk me home.
It's late and
you guys look like you can protect me.
Would you walk me home?
And they said, sure.
And I put my hand through this
arm of this guy and I'm like, so
where are you guys going?
It looks like you're celebrating.
My heart was pounding, and
they became my brothers.
And they walked me home.
Now-
>> [LAUGH]
>> It was risky.
And I'm not saying that'll work.
But that's what I was thinking about.
I was thinking about connecting and
humanizing, and
not escalating a situation that
could have gone a different way.
I really believe that that eye contact,
the humanity that people share,
can help you in a sticky situation.
All right [LAUGH] strange picture, right?
There's definitely a story about this.
My next tip, show faith in others.
I'm at Good Morning, America.
That gentleman over there
is Ron Reagan Junior.
President Reagan's son.
And he was a correspondent for GMA.
And we had to do this really boring
piece on how the lights are changed for
the Empire State Building.
And so every holiday, they change it and
we were going to interview the inventor of
the lights in the Billboards in New York.
And we were like, this is the most
boring piece, that we're stuck.
So Ron has this great idea.
He goes, I've got a great idea,
it's Empire State Building.
You'll be and
we'll get someone in a monkey suit.
And in every shot,
there'll be King Kong chasing you or
carrying you while you're flailing,
and it'll be a running joke.
And we're like, brilliant, hysterical.
So I had this intern Matt
had a little crush on me.
And I threw him a bone.
I'm like, Matt, would you like to be
in the monkey suit for the shoot?
And he's like, yes, please.
So we go to the Empire State Building.
We're in the 88th floor on the balcony.
Ron's inside with this really boring,
I mean,
this nice older man interviewing him.
And I'm in Matt's arms with
my arms around his neck.
And I'm waiting for
the director to say action.
And then I do something
I shouldn't have done.
I said, Matt, whatever you do,
don't drop me.
And they go action, and
he takes one step, trips, falls,
drops me on my back and
falls on top of me.
Monkey cement sandwich, not good.
I had to do the take 42 more times so
the bad back.
What I did is I made
this poor guy nervous.
I didn't show faith in him, right?
If I had just said,
this is going to be fun, let's do it.
And I've learned through my own life
that when someone shows doubt to me,
I doubt myself.
So as a leader, I try to be empowering and
I try to say, you can do this.
I believe in you.
It's the best gift you
can give to somebody.
Because if you think you doubt them,
they're going to doubt themselves and
they're not going to perform
to their best ability.
If you treat me like an idiot,
I'm going to act like one.
By the way Matt got me a nice
bag of Kiwis to apologize.
I really liked Kiwis back then.
So storytelling, how many by show of
hands know that I love storytelling?
Yeah, we all know this.
>> Storytelling is a weapon that I want
you all to use in your life, okay.
And my storytelling skills started early.
And I really thought about
why it's such a passion for
me, and
there are proof points along the way.
One, I was a very avid reader growing
up I used to read a book a night.
And for me, it taught me about dialogues
and emotions and interactions with people.
I mean,
I think that's why I like psychology too.
But how everything worked together and
I also was able to visualize
what things look like.
I always preferred books to movies.
And then my mother,
as crazy as it is, in New York City.
We walk and if a movie had already
started, my mom would take my brother and
I in halfway through.
I know child abuse right terrible and
we'd sit in the back row and for
an hour I'd have to figure out
what the heck is going on right.
And then we'd sit when the movie was over
everyone would leave they only had five
minute intermissions in those days in
the olden days when they had horse and
carriage.
And we'd stay and
I'd watch the first hour of the movie and
think did I get that right.
So what this taught me is I had to figure
out the plot draw inferences look for
verbal and visual cues.
It was pretty much strategic
communication right as a youngster.
And then I eavesdrop, I'm sorry if you've
ever seen me, I'm a big eavesdropper.
I like to go and read and eat,
but I would be listening in, and
I would be trying figuring out,
are you on a date?
Are you fighting?
And I'm going to watch your
body language and see,
does that person seem happy or not.
So yes, I do it, and if you see me at
Coupa, I'm probably eavesdropping on you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And then okay, we all know this, right.
I'm a pop culture fanatic.
I was faded my mother named me after
Allison Mackenzie from the first soap
opera ever on TV called Peyton Place.
So I was forced to be in pop culture and
media and that Mia Farrow,
she was a great actress at that point.
And then we know I have some
questionable reading material.
But during my teenage years I was paid to
read these magazines I had to look for
gossip and stories.
And it was important for me to know
who's doing what with whom, don't judge.
And then I have an interesting talent
where I have read every issue of
People Magazine since its inception.
I'm really good at table talk, and
I'm a lifeline for a lot of people and
who wants to be a millionaire.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So my other storytelling technique is I
love movies and
this was my favorite movie growing up.
And my best friend, Jamie,
at the time had never seen it, so
I forced her to watch it at home one night
on cable and then the cable went out.
So I started acting it out for
her and doing all the dialogues.
I must have seen it 20 times.
Then the cable came back on, and
I was way ahead of where the movie was.
So we started to watch it again.
And she looks at me
because you are a freak.
She's like,
I feel like I've seen this movie already.
It's crazy, you know, every line.
So what it showed was
my recall of dialogue,
my ability to act out scenes
visual communication.
And change my voice for each character
some vocal variety shown thrown in.
So there you go again,
strategic communication.
When you tell a story,
this is what you're telling people
I want you to know who I am.
I want you to know why I care about what
I care about and why I do what I do.
And I want you to know my strengths but
also my quirks.
And I want you to know what makes me
different from everybody else out there.
Maybe through my life experience,
maybe through my challenges, and
my story is going to prove
my credibility to you.
Even though I did something
that makes no sense.
10 years ago, I learned something from it.
All right, where's Erin raise your hand?
Okay, Erin knows the story, Erin was
born the year of the Missouri floods and
I told the story and
strategic communication she's like soon.
But really that resonates because I was
born I'm like the stories for you Erin.
So for those of you haven't heard
it Good Morning America sent me
to the Missouri floods.
This wasn't my favorite job was to book
live guests during big events like floods
but my first day I was in the helicopter
and I'm with the crew and
we're taking pictures.
Looking just like this, just the,
the tops of houses on water and
it was just a very horrifying experience.
To go over this, all this water and then
my job was to go to the Red Cross shelter.
Find a family and convince them to come
with our crew back to their house to
rescue pets or personal belongings.
So, I went to the Red Cross shelter.
I talked to the head of the fire
department, I got a boat.
And then I had to find a family, and there
was this man standing against a wall and
his family was sitting on
the ground next to him.
And I went over to him and I said,
hi, I'm from Good Morning America.
I have a crew and we have a boat.
Would you like to go
back to your house and
maybe rescue some of your personal items?
Well, he started to scream at me.
He said How dare you.
You want to exploit me at the worst
time in my life for National TV.
I have lost everything, am homeless.
You're going to go home in three days
to your warm house but am homeless.
And I just let him go on and
on and when he was done.
I put my hand on his arm and
I said, I am so sorry,
please accept my apology if I've
made this any worse for you.
I wish you luck,
God bless you and I walked away.
And about a minute later, I feel this tap
on my shoulder, and it's the man, and
he's like, so how would it work
with the boat and the crew?
And so my lesson which a lot
of my class has heard already,
is that storytelling goes both ways.
He needed to tell me his story and
I needed to listen.
He needed to get it off his chest and
be heard.
And I needed to understand
where he was coming from.
And when that trust was built, then he
wanted to do and by the way, he went back.
It was a great experience for him.
And he did rescue personal belongings.
And the executive producer called me and
said that was a great segment but
that wasn't the point.
And I always think back to this
is not doing the right thing.
So if I were to do it now or
even a few years after that,
because I think I was only about 22 or
23 at the time.
I would have said hi, I'm Allison
Kluger I'm from Good Morning America.
I am so sorry for what you're
going through I don't know if this
will help you at all, but
I have a boat and a crew.
Would you like to try to get
something from your house, and
would you like to show America
what is going on here?
So we can get more support?
That is how I would have approached it,
but sometimes you have to fumble, right.
To learn the right way to do something and
I always try to say never make
the same mistake twice hopefully.
So it was a big learning lesson.
Bob Marcus who gets in
reputation management says,
if I don't know how you've
struggled how can I connect to you?
So again it's that compassion,
it's asking people questions.
Why are you upset?
What can I do?
That's where the connection comes in.
So many of you know I teach with Tyra, and
we had Gary Vaynerchuk come in
to talk about social media.
And where to put your story and
the reassuring news from Gary was that
you don't have to use social media.
But if you are pick a platform
that works for you.
Whether it's Instagram and
its visual or Facebook or
whether you're in service of somebody and
you want to promote them.
But he said if you're going to do it,
stick with it and be on top of it.
But it's very important for
you to know where to take your story and
how to broadcast it.
You also need to know how
long to tell your story.
So for some people, just 30 seconds
might be enough of your narrative,
just the high points or
a minute and a half.
Or three minutes are sometimes five
minutes but if you don't know your
audience and you tell a really long
story you're going to lose them and
they're going to be frustrated
This is a really important point.
In my class is personal branding and
strategic pivoting, I make sure that my
last assignment is that my students
deliver a minute and a half narrative.
For personal branding, it's who I am, what
I've done and why I'm going to move into
this personal brand and
how it's going to be of service to you.
Strategic pivoting is what I've done,
who I am, why I want to pivot and
how it will benefit you very similar.
But the exercise is, if you can tell
your narrative in a minute and a half,
someone else can take that story and
carry it somewhere else,
where someone can be of service to you and
can create a new opportunity.
So this project was done in
a TV station before COVID.
And they'd go on live television and
have to do this narrative,
and it was broadcast.
So would you like to hear?
Let's hear some narratives.
I know some of my students have seen
this but it's worth seeing it again.
So this is from Project You.
[MUSIC]
>> Yeah.
[LAUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> Hi, I'm Nancy and
I love to live life out loud.
From the necklaces I love to rock to the
melanin I proudly wear on my skin, color
and vibrancy is such a huge part of who I
am, but it hasn't always been that way.
I was born with a disability in my arm and
my spinal cord called Compiz palsy.
Before I even knew my name, doctors put
limits on what I could achieve, and
they told my parents,
I can never live independently.
But I refused to believe that,
and I rebelled.
I saw how vibrant I could be,
and I grew a passion for
helping other people see their own
vibrancy, through photography.
Photography has shown me that I'm so
much bigger than this body, and
it's allowed me to connect with
people in deep and intimate ways.
I built my company Akos&Co to share
the stories of women of color,
it's been my absolute honor to share
their vibrancy with the world.
And it's my big hairy scary
dream to take this company from
being about photography
to a lifestyle brand.
Think cookware and interior design, but
designed with the needs and
wants of a woman in color in mind.
I want to help other women expose their
true color in every aspect of their lives.
>> Every time I see this, I'm moved.
You know so much about Nancy now.
You know she had a challenge,
you know she loves photography,
you know she wants to
create a lifestyle brand.
And there's enough there that
you could seriously just go and
talk about Nancy to someone else and
promote her.
She also was the embodiment
of what she said,
with the beautiful colorful
necklace she was wearing.
When she finished this class,
she took a black and white picture of
everyone in our class and gave it to us.
And she took that one to me.
It's one of my favorite headshots
because of course my hair looks awesome.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> [LAUGH] It's all about the hair.
All right,
this is from strategic pivoting.
[MUSIC]
>> Good evening, Sharks.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I really just always wanted to
say that.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Good evening coaches,
my name is Ross Pomerantz, and I'm in the
process of pivoting from enterprise sales
into something far more
disappointing to my parents.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Comedy writing.
>> Last week I did a poll for
20 of my closest friends and
family and I asked them what they
thought my greatest strength was.
20 out of 20 said humor.
Now, if that wasn't enough, ten years ago,
I was voted the fifth-funniest
person in my family.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And my brother, my dad,
my sister stuffed animal Chester,
and our blind pet parakeet.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So yes, I've been destined for
comedic greatness for a long time now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> The other strength that popped up was
discipline, which undoubtedly comes
from my background, playing baseball.
Where my only regret was I didn't
get a chance to strike that man out.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now, between humor and discipline,
I've been put in a very unique position.
My pilot started seven years ago, when
I started making comedy videos online.
I created an alter ego,
a persona called Corporate Bro,
in parity of Silicon Valley's sales life,
in parity on my life.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Fast-forward to today,
I have nearly 120,000 fans.
I've gotten millions of views
across all social media platforms.
And I even get invited to go speak at tech
companies, which is utterly ridiculous.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Now, that isn't where it ends,
I don't think.
The last year and a half I spent writing
a pilot TV show with my younger brother,
which frankly, I think Is our best work,
which is rare for
me to say because frankly I've
hated everything I've ever done.
So Alex, if you know anyone at WMV,
Allison if you know anyone in
the TV industry at all, or
Jenny if you know somebody at Google TV,
I would be honored to share it with them.
So I'm very excited to take my launch
because I have absolutely no idea where
I'm going to land on.
Thank you.
>> Fabulous, right?
Do you know a lot about Ross?
Did he not role model the humor?
I mean, you heard, we were a natural
laugh track, Alex, and the author,
Jenny from pivot and I were hysterical.
There was so much in there, it was a tad
too long, but he could shorten it, but
the point was you understood what
the building steps were to this pivot and
his credibility.
And he really knows his narrative, and
he's told me he's used it in
a lot of different forms.
So people tell you who you are I was a pen
my freshman year in creative writing,
I love creative writing, but
my teacher Biff Rose hated me.
And I was always like the goody two shoes
in English because I'm not a Math student,
as we all know.
But she hated writing, and I'd always get
low grades, and finally, I found out why.
And she said, Allison,
you have very complex thoughts, but
you write like People Magazine.
I'm not kidding, I had a People Magazine
in my backpack at that time.
But I did not whip it out and
I was humiliated.
I felt that I was stupid,
I felt that I was going to fail and that
she didn't appreciate anything I wrote.
But she told me what my brand was
at a very young age, messaging for
the masses, taking complex thoughts and
funneling them.
So that it's a very top line message.
And that is what you do in TV.
That is what you do in coaching.
And that's when you do in education.
So Biff did me a favor,
I just didn't listen hard enough, and
I was too young to appreciate that wisdom.
But I go back to it a lot, and think, wow,
I think my superpower
showed up really early.
So think about what
someone says about you.
You're so good at this or
I wish I could do this the way you did it.
Whatever it is,
think about what people tell you,
because they see how you land on them.
And they might be able to encourage you
in ways, you can't do for yourself.
So this is my son Logan,
he was about eight in this picture.
And this story is really
about when he was four,
have you heard of Bing Nursery School?
Think here at Stanford, okay?
So getting my son's into Bing was
harder than getting into the GSB.
I'm not kidding,
I wrote it a kick-ass letter and
I got them in because I really felt
to be the best school for them.
And I was at orientation and when they
were talking about half acre of playroom
and play and everything they talked about.
And I was almost crying, thinking,
my God, I'm so happy my son is here,
this is such a privilege.
So about two weeks into it,
I went to drop Logan off.
And the head teacher Sarah, who's
really tall in English pulled me over.
She said Alison, Logan learned a new word.
And I'm like great,
let's hear the brilliance.
She goes, it's fuck.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I go pale and I'm like, uh-huh, and
she goes with any idea where
he may have heard that word?
So I say well, I'm sure it's for me,
I said where else would he hear it?
I said I don't know when and
where, but it was probably me.
She's like it's okay, other kids curse but
we just don't want you to
think they learned it here.
And don't worry about it,
and I said, no problem.
And I went back to my car and cried.
I'm like, I'm in the best school and
now they think I'm the worst mom,
my kids cursing up a storm.
So I go to pick them up later on and
Sarah calls me over,
Allison, did you go to your car and cry?
>> [LAUGH].
>> I said, yeah, I did.
And she's like Allison.
So that's why we love you
because you're the only
parent who has ever admitted it was them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This happens all the time.
She says, we trust you, you're so
endearing and we became so close.
And I ended up doing the auction thing and
the annual fun, but
that was where my trust was built.
And Sarah's still a dear friend.
So the more transparent you are,
the more people trust you.
We know this from the trust radar and
reputation management.
There's shame in hiding the truth.
It's much bigger burden on you to try to
hide who you are and what you've done.
Own it your candor will inspire
others to also be honest.
All right don't be afraid
to share your truth.
I was at Qualtrics a few
years ago before COVID.
And I got to see three of my heroes
Oprah and Sir Richard Branson and Obama.
And then this gentleman came out to speak,
his name was Billy McDermott,
CEO of SAP, I didn't know who he was.
I was in an audience of 11,000 people,
so I'm sure I wasn't alone, but
he came out very good looking guy, salt
and pepper hair, but wearing sunglasses.
And he sat down in this dark auditorium,
and started talking to Andy the Moderator.
And all I could think of is,
why is he wearing sunglasses?
Is he too cool for us?
Is he Jack Nicholson?
What's he trying to say?
Because I'm always looking at signals and
I'm so distracted by his glasses that I do
something I rarely do, which is I
pulled up my phone, which no one should
ever do when they're in an auditorium
>> [LAUGH]
>> And I look at my phone and
I look them up.
And sure enough, he's had an accident.
He was walking down the stairs and he
tripped and he was holding a glass and it
shattered and a shard of glass went into
his eye and he had all these surgeries.
So what I was thinking was if I had
coached him, I would have said,
look Billy,
you've got to know your audience.
You've 11,000 people 10%
won't know who you are.
And they're going to make assumptions.
So before you start talking you say, hey,
I just want to let you know, I had some
surgeries on my eye I need to wear
glasses, I'm not giving you any shade.
And then, you go on.
And then all of a sudden,
you feel empathy, you feel closer,
you feel connected.
And you're not distracted from
the reason he's actually there.
So the lesson is, say who you are,
share your experiences be authentic and
don't make excuses.
Don't be embarrassed for who you are,
your stories tell a tale and
they help people connect to you.
So why should you create a narrative?
I know you've heard me
say this many times.
It's more interesting
to start with a story.
People can carry your story.
It helps you connect and
it's you at your most authentic.
What makes you stand out in the crowd?
You're all brilliant here.
What makes you stand out?
Each of you has something
that makes you stand out.
So you have to figure out
your differentiating factor,
your secret sauce is what I like
to call it, your zone of genius.
What do people again,
tell you about yourself?
All of you who've done the pee rap, right?
My god.
So
I apologize to everyone had
to take the surveys, but
you learned what do people say about you?
When you figure out your secret sauce and
superpower you need to leverage it.
So number nine, it's not what happens.
It's how you deal with it.
Reputation management started that way,
it is my mantra,
it will probably go on my gravestone.
Shit happens, it's going to happen,
how are you dealing with it?
How you deal with it says way more
about you, than what actually happened.
So, what if you have a reputation for
being unapproachable, sarcastic,
arrogant, late, blaming others,
being too quiet and not speaking up,
not joining in activities.
Well, you can behave your
way to a new reputation.
This is from Joe Peterson when he
guested in my class, but an example for
you is let's say you know someone,
you're someone who is habitually late.
And it's kind of funny and it's quirky,
and people think this person but
what it's saying is your time
isn't as valuable as my time is.
I don't respect your time and
after a while it's not cute anymore.
So what I said to someone as I said
you can change this reputation by
being consistently early.
So get to the next meeting early, and
everyone's going to say, what are you
doing here early, you're always late?
And you'll say, no, no,
I'm going to be early for now.
And they're like, okay, then you show
up the next meeting and you're early,
like, you're still doing the early thing.
And you'll yep,
still doing the early thing.
And then you keep showing up early and
early.
And all of a sudden that old reputation
of being late has now been put to bed.
And you don't even have a reputation for
it anymore.
What I love about this example is
you're not stuck in a reputation.
You can always be fluid and tweak
something that you think you could do
better and then consistently show up and
you will create that new reputation.
I really believe in choosing to
engage in difficult conversations.
I think many of us would rather sweep it
under the rug or hope it passes by but
from my experience people
hold on to these things and
that becomes a fixed bias about you.
And so have those hard conversations
because I don't think you want to leave
things unsaid and especially as you
are getting ready to leave here.
If there's anybody who you feel you
have a misunderstanding with, and
you think,
it's too late to confront that, it's not.
I called up Amy, that producer from the
Home Shopping Network last year, after not
speaking to her for over 20 years and
say can we talk about what happened?
And we talked about and
she apologized to me.
And it was a hard conversation that
I avoided for a very long time, but
it really healed me.
It also teaches you how to
verbalize complex thoughts.
You should be able to have
difficult conversations at work and
in your personal life and not be
intimidated by the emotions involved.
It teaches you how to advocate for
yourself.
I was really hurt by this but
I want to hear what you were thinking.
It also creates trust because people
will know that you're an honest,
forthright person.
And, it helps you control
your own narrative.
So, it's not what you say,
it's how you say it.
I think I said this earlier.
You can say anything to anyone.
If you say it in a way that is kind,
compassionate and straightforward and
candid.
I do believe you can spin
anything into a positive.
And so let's say you got fired and
you're embarrassed and
you don't want to talk about this.
Well, you have two ways of doing it.
One you can say, this job is terrible,
like someone who's interviewing you and
says, why were you only there for
six months?
You say, well, I was promised this and
it never happened, and they were terrible.
[LAUGH] What does that say about you?
How about you say,
you know what when I went to that job,
I thought I was going to be doing this and
this, and it didn't work out that way.
But in the six months I was there,
I learned this, this and this and
now I'm even more prepared
to be here with you.
So how you message something
tells people about you but
you can put a positive spin on anything
even if it's not the greatest experience.
I've had jobs that I had to squeeze
into a round peg into a square hole.
And, that doesn't really
make sense [LAUGH].
But you know what?
I would always try to
find one thing of value.
Maybe meeting a new person,
or a mentor, or a new skill.
So again, we're back to,
if not you then who?
And I want you to opt in and
figure it out.
Okay, all of us have opportunities
that are presented to us but
many times we say it's not us,
I'm not ready for that.
And that's because it's scary to opt in,
or we're feeling lost in life and
we don't want to take anything new on.
Or we're doing what we're doing
to make others happy, but
we're not thinking about
what we really want.
We're afraid to take a risk,
we're not feeling authentic, and
we have imposter syndrome.
But I'm going to remind you that when
you're asked to opt in to do something,
the deliverable is never
five minutes later.
So if someone says I want
you to do this project, or
I want you to get this promotion, or I
want you to go on this offsite and you're
like, [SOUND] just think okay, say yes,
thank you, and then you go break it down.
And you can research it, ask questions,
fill in the knowledge gaps.
But you are all sitting here,
the most capable human beings,
you're here because you
know how to do this.
So just take those
opportunities when they come,
don't get all that negative
self talk in your head.
And say what, I'll figure it,
out I'm smart enough to figure it out.
So use your origin story
to create your narrative,
you're all thinking what's my narrative?
Well you go back to your origin story,
a lot of this, forgive
me if you this is going to be redundant
I'm going to go through it quickly but
some of you don't know it.
So using my own experience I went to Penn,
I interned at TV stations,
I started a Good Morning America three
days later I worked there eight years,
I went to the shopping network,
I got on air, I sold barbecues.
[LAUGH] And after that,
I went into the control room and
I led the whole show which I really loved.
And then I was wooed away to another
shopping network where I was the executive
producer, 16 hours of live television.
I was the face of the network,
I created shows, hired and
fired, and then this was me doing a promo,
let's see it.
Hi, I'm Allison Kluger, your host for
designers corner here at GSN.
We get New York City designers
to bring in their jewelry, and
all the jewelry is like a piece of art.
Each one is handcrafted,
semi precious stones, unique design and
you can't find it anywhere else.
You don't have to wander around
the streets downtown looking for
that very special piece of jewelry.
We're going to bring it to you.
We're going to bring you the piece of
jewelry that's beautiful, interesting,
that you can't find anywhere else
with the price that you can afford.
So be sure to catch me here at GSN,
the smart shoppers channel.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Right, yeah.
[LAUGH] Someone had to do it, right?
And you don't want to
wander around looking for
that very special piece of jewellery,
let me do it for you.
Anyway, then I was wooed over by the view,
Barbara Walters was my idol,
I had known her when I was an intern and
I always wanted to work with her.
I know that she's old and
you probably don't know her but
she was a pioneer, and
I was like the thrill of my life.
And then my husband went to the GSB and
I had to move to here and
be an SO or an SOB.
And I had to support us and go into,
I started a .com for women,
I was a.com disaster, open TV snap me up.
I was an executive producer there.
Then when I finished, I did a year with Al
Gore and I helped him set up current TV.
I took that job just to work with him,
not for
the money cause believe
me there was no money.
And then, after seven I'm sorry,
nine in Vitros and
three years of trying,
I had trouble and more trouble.
And I took seven years off to raise them.
And I did start my own media consulting
business, but it was far and few between
the amount of times I actually worked,
because I was their sole caretaker.
My husband was starting up companies.
And then I came to this place,
which is a very trite photo, but
it really says what I felt.
And a lot of you might be there right now,
or in 10 years you might be there.
And I just had to say,
what's my narrative, right?
So I figured these are the things
I'm really good at.
And no matter where I go and what I do,
I'm going to bring this to it.
So don't be afraid to repackage yourself.
There are times you're
going to be pivoting.
going to recreate yourself.
But everything you need is there,
you just have to cherry pick it out.
So here's the exercise that I teach
in project U and strategic pivoting.
So again, many of you know it,
but for those who don't,
it's called cake and icing.
I visualize this exercise from this book,
and cake is what you really do well,
it's your rational value,
it's your functional skills.
Your icing is what people say about
you and how they describe you.
And together they make your strong brand,
but they also enable
you to tell your story.
So now with all those jobs I
told you about listed up here,
what I do is I write down my
cake underneath each one.
What are the talents?
What's my functional benefits I can do?
And then you see what keeps popping up.
Well, I always create content,
I'm innovative, oops, I'm problem solving,
I coach talent, and
I'm an expert at messaging.
Look how many times that pops
up in my weird timeline, right?
And then my icing.
This is what people would say about me,
and if you don't know those words you ask
your friends,
do a survey I really recommend surveys.
And so these are the things that I
also deliver, what people think.
Now, if I were to create a narrative I
might go to each one of these steps and
pick out an anecdote or
story under each one that shows my skills,
that proves my credibility,
that shows a failure and a triumph.
And that is how you can curate stories for
your narrative.
So present the solution,
not the suggestion.
I see I'm running out of time.
I'm going to have to be super fast.
How many people know the Tyra
story before I go into it?
Show of hands.
Okay, I have to tell it that,
I'm going to be really quick.
Tyra came here on SMX, I was in
the front row, I watched all her shows.
And she talked about personal branding.
And she was so amazing and
talked about her roles changing.
And I'm sitting here going,
I gotta teach with her.
And I force my way backstage
with no permission.
And I have a 32nd narrative, and I say,
hi Tyra, I'm Allison Kluger, I teach here.
I was a TV producer at the view
in Good Morning America, and
I know you've been on both shows.
I want to teach a course with you on
personal branding, a compressed course,
what do you think?
And she was, I don't know.
And I'm like, no, I have a great idea.
And I said,
I learned more from you in one hour.
And she's like, okay, and she gives me
her card and we make an appointment for
a week later.
In that week I go back and
I start creating the whole course,
all six classes.
What are the textbooks
that I want to read?
Who are going to be the guests?
What's every segment about?
I'm going to stream it live on
Facebook to be differentiated.
I'm going to come out of a live
TV station for the final project.
We'll do visual branding.
And I put it all together with all
the compressed course dates that
were available, and then I talked to her
again for a few hours, and I'm like, so
here's the outline,
what do you want to do?
And she was amazing.
She was, I can do this, and
I can do that, and blah blah blah, and
she was the most brilliant
marketer I have ever met.
And she made it easy and said,
okay, this is all great.
And I said, give me the two weeks you can
do and you have to be here every day.
And she's like, okay.
And give me a backup, and she's okay.
Then I went and
redid the whole proposal, and
then I anticipated what all the push
back would be from the dean.
And then I thought about how
I'm going to handle all that.
And then I went to the assistant
dean of the Business School.
And I said, I want to teach a course
with Tyra Banks, she's a business woman,
here's her proof, this is the course, this
is how it's going to benefit our students,
this is how it's going to be
different from all the other courses,
these are the takeaways, these are out
textbooks, these are our guests.
And he asked me every
question I anticipated,
starting with Tyra is not our brand,
I don't think she's the right person.
I'm like, she is.
[LAUGH] And he said yes.
So, the lesson here is that
I would say no there she is.
I'm going to go back quickly.
Present the solution, not the suggestion.
And the reason I say this is that if I
had gone the day after Tyra was here and
went to the assistant dean and
said, I think I want to teach with Tyra I
have this idea, he would have said no.
Absolutely not and
I would have been dead in the water and
that would have been it for me.
So if you want to create change for
yourself, don't complain about things,
don't identify the problems.
Create the solutions,
just go to an interview and say,
I've looked at your website and you're
missing this, and I'd love to take over.
And I want to be in charge and this is
the budget, but this is just a tip for
those of you who aren't as bold or
need more time or introverted.
But it's worked for me a lot and
it's probably my number one tip, and
then I did it with Alex.
I created the course ahead of time.
Alex was available to guests speak,
I wasn't sure they'd let him, but
the course now exists and
that's what we did, that's one of my tip.
So I'm telling you to be authentic you and
I'm telling you all these things you need
to do that might push you out
of your comfort zone, right.
So finally, my last story is I was
crying a Good Morning America.
I was about two months in,
I was almost 21.
And this woman, Sonia Selby, right, an
English producer, I was scared of her too.
She pulled me in her office and
she shut the door and said, Allison,
I don't ever want to see you crying.
Do you know why?
And I was like.
And intuitively I knew I but
I knew she was going to tell me.
And she says, because you're young,
you're female and you're attractive and
no one is going to trust you.
No one is going to give
you responsibility and
no one's going to think you're reliable.
She goes, if you're having a bad day,
you come in my office and
you can close the door.
But if someone says to you, how are you?
You say I'm great.
Do you understand?
I said, yes.
And she was, get outta here.
And so she threw me out of the office and
of course, what did I want to do, cry, but
I didn't, but this was an epiphany for me.
And this was how I became the leader I
want to be, I wanted to be reliable,
I wanted to be respected,
I wanted to be given the hard work.
And so I became unflappable.
And they'd say go to Alison
she can take care of her.
Go to Alison she's really
easy to work with.
Go to Alison, she's a problem solver.
And then I went to jobs
that I was on air and
in the control room where
anything could go wrong.
So by showing up every day,
the way I wanted to show up,
is how I created the reputation and
how I became the leader I want to be,
even though I was a very shy kid, and
obviously I cry a lot, I still do but,
that's how I showed my fear.
So, act like the leader you want to be and
it becomes authentic.
Everyone can do it.
You're not cheating yourself
out of your true personality.
These are the leaders who I want to be
like Barbara Walters for her work ethic,
Oprah for transparency,
Obama for integrity and empathy.
Michelle Obama inspirational and
powerful and then of course,
Ruth Bader Ginsburg for breaking barriers.
Those were my North Stars,
figure out who yours are.
So, what are my takeaways for today?
Lead with love, compassion over
aggression, when down, do for others,
storytelling is a secret weapon,
differentiate yourself.
Choose to engage in those hard
conversations, spin it into a positive,
present the solution not the suggestion,
opt in and figure it out later,
and act like the leader you want to be.
Because, if not you then who?
Thank you
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Kendy [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you everybody.
>> Thank you so much Allison.
I think we have time for one or
two quick questions, and
then you can probably catch
Allison outside for any follow up.
>> My God, all right..
>> For any follow up.
>> I'm excited, not nervous for
those questions I don't know.
Who's got a questions to stone me?
Yes.
>> The mic is actually right behind
you if you want in the cup holder.
>> How convenient.
Did you plant that person?
>> Hello.
>> Okay.
>> Hi, Alison.
Thank you so much.
So I think one of the greatest gifts from
coming to the GSB is just the platform
it gives us to share a message or
just a cause that we really care about.
I love to hear how you think about
when you choose to step in and
out of the public eye,
and how you manage that.
And also to that, how you stay authentic,
when so much of what we're pitching is
sometimes to our loved ones and to our
masses, and sometimes feels inconsistent.
How do we close that gap?
>> Thank you for that question.
I don't always choose
sometimes I'm chosen.
And then I have to opt in.
And so I would say that I've had impostor
syndrome probably my entire first 45
years of my life.
I'm only 30.
So I don't really know how that
math works, but
>> [LAUGH]
>> But, many times I've been tapped on
the shoulder to do something, or someone's
come to me and said, Alison we want
you to be on air, and I will battle with
the fear and I'll force myself to do it.
And by the way, the reality is never
as scary as what you think it is.
We build it up in our heads.
So the outward facing me is
just from challenging myself.
When I started teaching here
I had another epiphany, and
my epiphany is I'm going to
say yes to everything.
At this point in my career
I know what I'm good at.
I worked really hard to create
a course here and if I can't do it,
I'm going to say I can't do it or
I'm going to find someone who can.
So in being authentic about it, I just
I'm very clear what I'm not good at,
we all know I'm not
going to do accounting and
budgeting but I know what I'm
really good at and I lean into it.
I hope that answers your question.
Yes.
>> Chris is right behind you.
Perfect.
>> Hi,
>> Hi, Miriam.
>> Hi [LAUGH]
>> Glad you made it,
>> That was amazing.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah, thanks for reminding me.
My questions about your
slides on transparency and
being infront upfront with people.
I'm just wondering Is that always the case
or has it been time where it's better to
not speak up or say something on
your mind in a certain situation?
>> I've grown into that as well.
And thank you for
that great question, Miriam.
I'm a great believer that the more you
are transparent or have radical candor
is people in reputation management
know the gift you're giving people.
They don't have to work so
hard to figure you out.
And I've always said, some of my students
are actually shy or introverted and yet
when they did the reputation survey,
people would say, you seem arrogant or
rude so you don't care about me.
And I say that's because you're shy and
you're quiet, but
people are making assumptions about you,
because they just want to be friends with
you, and they think you're rejecting them.
So, sometimes it's good to say,
I'm not the most social person but
I'm really happy to be here.
But front load the information you want,
just like Billy McDermott.
There are different
shades of transparency,
if it's going to diminish
your power in a job.
Then I might find a better
way to say something but
I always believe that
eventually the truth outs.
And if you're working so hard to be
you're not it's gonnabe exhausting.
And I think ultimately we all want to
be accepted and appreciated for
who we truely are and
what we bring to table.
And for the things we feel insecure about,
we can ask for help.
But if you don't broadcast and say,
you know what, I'm not so good with this.
I need some help.
Everyone wants to help you.
So I hope that answered your question.
I think that transparency
is a personal thing.
But I'm a pretty open book,
and it's worked well for
me except when I called Amy a bitch.
That was not good but I learned from that.
Thank you for the question.
>> Thank you so much Alison.
>> Thank you all.
[APPLAUSE] I love you all.